can we
linger on the spike protein for a little
bit is is there something interesting
or like beautiful you find about it i
mean first of all it's an incredibly
challenging protein and so we as a part
of uh our
sort of uh research to understand
the structural basis of this virus to
sort of decode structured decode every
single
protein in its proteome um
which you know we've been working on
this spike uh
protein and uh one of the main
challenges was that
um the uh cryovm
uh data allows us to
reconstruct or to obtain the 3d
coordinates of roughly
two-thirds of the protein the
rest of the one-third of this protein
it's a part that
is buried into the into the membrane
yeah
of the virus and uh of the of the
viral envelope and uh it also
has a lot of unstable structures around
it
so it's chemically interacting somehow
with whatever the heck it's connecting
yeah so so it people are still trying to
understand so so the
the nature of and the the role of this
uh you know uh
of this uh one third because the the top
part
uh you know the the primary function is
to
get attached to the you know h2 receptor
human receptor there is also beautiful
you know mechanics of how this thing
happens right
so because there are three different
copies of this
uh chains or you know there are
three different domains right so we're
talking about domains so this is the
receptor binding domains
rbgs that gets untangled
and get ready to to atta to get attached
to
to the receptor and now
they are not necessarily going
in a sync mode as a matter of fact
it's asynchronous yeah so yes so and
this is this is where you know
the another level of complexity comes
into play because
you know right now what we see is
we typically see just one of the arms
going out and getting ready to to
be attached to the uh to the ac2
receptors however
there was a recent mutation that
people studied in that spike protein
and a uh
very recently a group from umass medical
school
uh we happened to collaborate with
groups so this is a group of
jeremy lubin and a number of uh
other faculty they uh
actually uh solved the uh
the mutated structure of the spike and
they showed that
actually because of these mutations you
have
more than one arms
opening up and so now so you so the
frequency
of two arms going up
incre increase quite you know
drastically how interesting
is that does that change the dynamics
somehow it potentially
can change the dynamics of because now
you have
two possible opportunities to get
attached
to the ac2 receptor it's a very complex
molecular process mechanistic process
but the first step of this
process is the attachment of this
spike protein of the spike trimer
to the human h2 receptor so this is a
molecule that sits
on the surface of the human cell
and that's essentially what initiates
the what triggers the whole process of
you know encapsulation well uh if this
was dating this would be the first date
so this is the uh the way yes
so is it is it possible to have the
spike protein just like floating about
on its own or does it need that
interactive ability with the
uh with the membrane yeah so it needs to
be attached
at least as far as i know but uh you
know
when you get this thing attached on the
surface right there is also
a lot of dynamics on where how it sits
on the surface right
so for example uh there was a recent
work
in uh again uh where people use the
cryogen microscopy to get the first
glimpse of the overall structure it's a
very low res but
you still get some interesting details
about the surface about what is
happening inside because we have
literally no clue until recent work
about
how the the capsid is organized
so capsid is essentially it's the inner
core
of the viral particle where the uh there
is a
the rna of the virus and it's protected
by
another protein and protein
that essentially acts as a shield
but you know now we are learning more
and more so it's actually it's not just
this shield it's you is potentially is
used
for the stability of the outer shell of
the
of the virus so it's it's pretty
complicated
and as i mean understanding all of this
is really useful for trying to figure
out like developing a vaccine or some
kind of
drug to attack any aspects of this right
so i mean there are
many different implications to that i
mean first of all
you know it's it's important to
understand the virus
itself right so you know in order to uh
to understand how it
acts what is the overall mechanism
mechanistic process
of this virus replication of this virus
proliferation to the cell
right so so that's one uh aspect the
other
aspect is you know designing new
treatments right so one of the
uh possible treatments is uh you know
designing nanoparticles
and so some nanoparticles that will
resemble
the viral shape that would have the
spike integrated
and essentially would act uh as a
competitor to the real virus
by blocking the ac2 receptors
and thus preventing the real virus
entering the cell
you